ah
um
welcome to the shiva
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
shiva is over in tamil nadu
in india and
he has been a critical
node in catalyzing awakening
especially on instagram
and he's been a super connector of those
that
are already awakened are
awakening and he's
created several catalytic flames
for me myself and my awakening
so i'm really grateful
and pumped for this
shiva's also been interviewing
people that are
awakened and he is
link is in the bio below
for people that want to follow him
and send him a message and
potentially be interviewed as well and
it's a really great way
to link people up that are awakened to
create even more ignition of the
awakening
and i have had several back and forths
now about
let's awaken and enlighten the planet
which we're jacked about
there's so many forces right now that
are in that process
which is very exciting
[Music]
start with some let's start with some
background on you brother
let's start with some background tell us
about how you awakened
well uh there's this thing called joint
entrance examination
in india which
is uh to put people into engineering
colleges premier engineering colleges
i went to one and i didn't like it that
i it's far away from home so returning
from there wasn't
welcome in my home attending the
engineering class classes
weren't welcome to my lighting and
of course the fosters were full of all
kinds of voices so
just being there was an ominous energy
uh as time passed i realized i couldn't
keep living like this
going to college not liking it going to
hostel not working with us
not being welcomed by my parents to drop
out
as days passed by i walked one day
i having no guru having no spiritual
technique
uh just for my solace i used to feed the
dogs
i used to run a lot and that was pretty
much it that was uh
my drug that was how i was getting by
one day full of when well
living in this stressful situation and
the flight of light all the time was
wreaking havoc on my nervous system one
day i
uh walk alone just to feed dogs
uh carrying a whole bunch of indian
bread in my hand
i hear in my mind you last for two days
after that it's over uh
and uh at that point of time nothing
mattered neither my
neither my engineering degree nor my
family background or
not the life ahead if i'm going to die
and enlightenment is the
only purpose of life who dies a failure
who dies unenlightened
uh it's uh it's a dark night
the night was pretty dark and it's a
lonely stretch of the road
i walk and
it's just me converting against my
conversing against my mind
my mind says to me go to hostel you have
class tomorrow
i i reply attending the class is fine
not attending it is fine but who has to
attend
any of the rules uh i had enough of it
and my mind says your ankles hurt a lot
ankle sweating is fine not hurting is
fine
the ankles will hurt tomorrow but i
still haven't
awakened and the third step is
i get a fed up of just conversing with
the mind
it's just workplace and it leads to
nowhere it's just weird
intellectualization
and i just narrowed down to the question
who has to go through all this
who and who just push it really against
myself
i take five steps storming in anger
the blood rushes to my face so much
energy rest to my face
and from the sixth step it cooled down
on its own
that was the moment i knew i had broken
into something
i go to the hostel look inside the
mirror
my eyes had changed i
from the hospital well i'm just a
college kid from the hospital i go to
the dining hall
try to eat food my hand reaches for the
food
it almost comes to my mouth but i'm i'm
not the body
consciousness doesn't need food i've
done it
and then i go to sleep i close my eyes
but
it's almost like well i'm very awake i
turn right i'm aware i turn left timer
mind essence racing go here do this
the track the struggles of 20 something
the mind doesn't racing like that
it is it's in deep sleep but i'm still
aware
in the morning i woke up uh that
hourglass hadn't changed
that's been my
and for three days uh i was totally in
that state and i was losing control over
all my abilities very fast
i knew keeping in touch with it my body
would wouldn't last
its go time forever
so i had to think a lot and load my mind
with impressions and impressions and
impressions
finally get one module working
and with it get access to all the
modules working and now my ego
is back with all its modules with all
its belts and reserves and
how old are you back then i didn't have
a teacher and
with engineering not being to my liking
uh my mind was stuck in all sorts of
ruts i
didn't have anything to break through so
i used energy a lot
he just used to walk a lot
yeah just relate on shear force and at
the moment of awakening
that shear force came he came in handy
there was this wall who does all this
and
the well the mind knows it cannot break
it cannot break through it mind is
limited
so just the shear force of it help me
break the wall who does all this
who does all
fifth semester and i'm doing something
very different
i'm taking i've taken photography and
shiva how old are you i'm 21 now
but at that moment i'm 29 now but at the
moment of awakening i was 17.
yes i love it
ah this is so
perfect you
sock man is also 20 years old
i love the youth right now being
awakened it's so delicious
yeah the story for you
with your
sort of matrix force
of the culture and the parents
and the you engineer and then they have
all these other forces
of culture that are about becoming
profession
doctor finance all this type of stuff
you have to make money in nine to five
and so it's cool that
you through the process of
asking who who has to go to class
and then the my it's cool because you
created a juxtaposition
you basically created the very
where if if this is the mind that's
barking
all the time and this is the modulating
this is the modulating and you're
wondering
who's this who who is the screen
what is the screen yeah exactly
and that's great that you created that
juxtaposition for yourself even without
spirituality without guru just by asking
the question
super easy or super interesting not
as i think you have a good story about
how simple it is
too but it's also difficult like you
said because there are these days of
losing your faculties
where what
do we do when we're in emptiness
and when we come
back to the physical there's a process
of in a sense integrating
some of said capacities again
people kind of look a little bit weird
if you just kind of sit there like
people are like is this person alive
what's going on
do they need medical help
and so it's um so there is a process of
integration
and so so would you say that you landed
at
you land at this
this very empty formlessness that
is the source of infinite possibility
and is this awareness this consciousness
is that right
yeah it's like that in your heart
when all the waves get lifted and you
like so many universes so many beings
and over such a period of time and this
is it
all you had to do was break two or three
things in your own mind two or three
patterns and this is it
that's a good one it's like that but
then
you do land uh well just asking
you to break through all the all the
modules and
you could take to all the modules and
land right in the consciousness then
the infinite source well yeah
uh cross your own mind and you cross the
infinite mind
well after awakening energies are going
off
uh stuff that were not already active
which were dormant are now active and
now
in my now in my control
and uh enlightenment is called second
birth
in advaita vedanta and in buddhism uh
it is like a kid learning to walk
and how he learns this exponential it's
so crazy dude
and so it was a very new place for me
and people around me couldn't understand
uh well i wasn't in a periscope
condition at that time i was very
frantic
i couldn't well i i walked so much
uh till till till the point of my
enlightenment and
after the enlightenment i couldn't stay
still or
said still i had to walk a lot and
people wondered what's wrong with him
and
i couldn't maintain eye contact with
people for so long
i and of course these two
caught their attention and
well i had to stay uh well after the
awakening
and me sensing energies the fifth floor
vary was put in
where all the drug users and the junkies
and the delinquents and
all those people all the anti-social
elements
well i'm an anti-social element too but
well i stuck out for a different reason
well where all those people were
just entering the fifth floor made the
energy so heavy
and it was such a disturbing feeling i
had to stay
stay out outside and i used to sleep in
the ground
i used to sleep in the clock room
which was open only when people were
leaving the home and
had to keep the luggage and department
home
so i had to sleep i was basically
homeless for the next four months after
awakening and
people thought i was an insomniac i was
sleeping quite well
and people thought he was too alone well
i i couldn't
i don't know maybe some energetic thing
that setting me apart was happening
and i was with the dogs all the time
so people couldn't figure me out and
just caught the attention of my
professors and you know
my grades were very poor well
yeah yeah and they
taught me uh they took me to be they
took me to the psychiatrist and the
psychiatrist diagnosed me to be a
schizophrenic
and i was taking online for one whole
year
staying in staying in my home uh
it it was kind of a blessing because the
college was
so successful i got to rest at home for
here
but the tablets wreak havoc on your
nervous system and they poison your
nervous system
so and this is again where sciences
spirituality comes in
well just confined by rationality
science asks you to
later normal life conform to the society
and to the education and to the parents
and to the culture of course
science cannot define consciousness the
the farthest it has gone as defined it
as the heart problem of consciousness
and it left it there and it asks you to
meditate
which is to the greater will which is
not to the greater benefit
spirituality on the other hand lets you
be free
asks you to purify yourself says it's
all inside
it's not something that is said and you
have to mechanically take it it's all
inside
it's you have the control and
spirituality has a very good back
backing on consciousness
so purifying not medicating is the
answer to
the i i don't agree with the whole
movement of psychiatry
okay beautiful we have a couple ways to
hit the ball back here
one of them is that it's
nuts that
we have these trampolines
awakening and then there's no landing
zones
and so then you have this whole thing
with like i'm homeless for four months
i nobody understands i'm
diagnosed for schizophrenia
which there's a bunch of disastrous
problems with that which we'll talk
about
there's a lot of dirty bath water and we
need to sort of take out
the baby which we'll talk about in a
moment and
then the whole year long of
pharmaceuticals
creating neurobiological havoc and
then
one of the things that i would say
around science and spirituality
is that science is like the analysis of
form science is like when you
analyze the
specific food item if this creation
is a beet salad science is the analyzers
of the beet salad but next
creation we're going to get chicken soup
and it's going to be a different
analysis of form yeah for the soul
and so this is what we have to
understand is that science
is the analysis affinity the analysis of
form and it's very important because
it's what's enabling us to have this
conversation right now
and so we have to respect the math and
physics and biology and chemistry it's
like thank you thank you there's very
good things here we understand that
yet at the same time spirituality is the
study of
metaphysics it's the study of infinity
it's the study of the
realignment
towards the one heart when you're
distracted and distorted by maya and the
contractions
spirituality is like turn inward turn
inward turn inward
realign realign realign and so
ultimately is a synthesis between the
two you drain the dirty bath water from
both you bring the two together and
merge them into one
because it's just the mind that's
separating them anyway
and so i really like the synthesis there
and then i like your point
as well about all you have to do is
break these two to three patterns in
your own mind it's
really fundamentally it
is that it's just the contracted
identity and the perpetual
uh yeah it just perpetuates itself
anything uh that doesn't agree with it
just perpetuates
it's this one
this one be here now which way should we
go
how long will it take to get there where
is that how far away is it how do we get
there
and we have you know that's one of them
you know this is another one of them
that's really good
you know before spiritual awakening
you're the victim
and after spiritual awakening you
understand that you created your own
you are creation you are the entirety of
creation
you are the very source of the infinite
possibility itself
snapping yourself yes yes
and we'll ge yeah we'll get to some more
of these good ones
um this these are some of them from
shiva's page
as well the girlfriend promised me to be
normal around my parents this time
okay i promise her dad so what do you do
for fun
me what do you mean by you
and we'll get to some more of those here
in a bit
just wanted to at least you know bring
up the fundamental patterns that we're
talking about
are why does the mind constantly bring
you into the past
or into the future
why does it make you anxious or
depressed
yeah that's one of the
great freedoms of liberation uh the
doomsday effect
like there's some impending room and the
paranoia of it just goes away
if needed you can be with the humans and
take part
in the dharma uh otherwise you can be
alone otherwise you can
drop dead and dissolve for good
yeah oh
i would say that the rumination in the
past
and the future like you said the
doomsday
mind the impending doom mind
is one of these patterns
and then i would say another one of the
patterns
is that
the mind wants to separate
everything so the mind wants to
yes the mind wants to say that shiva is
different than
atlas and that this glass of water is
different than
atlas and shiva but then you ask the
simple question can make the mind
realize oneness which is where is the
boundary
where where is the boundary between
the very oxygen that you inhale every
breath where is the boundary
and so these little pattern breaks
that you can make will help you
recognize the very unity
of it all
well when once you play call the
boundary store
the place where the boundaries exist is
also crossed over
the mind is the concept of the mind and
that's how ridiculous it is
the mind is a concept of the mind
and uh one little riddle uh one who am i
uh just to solve the entire adult
existence
it is uh just when life gets
it is when it gets mind-boggling that
you
don't turn inside and ask the questions
and ask the questions that really matter
and that's only one question another
thing
about who am i dude when people ask me
so many questions
so many questions which are of no use
i just put through in front of it
and ask them the same question back
well uh
do you dissolve the do you dissolve the
boundaries of
the mind when you awaken who dissolves
the bounty of the mind when you're
awakened
do you think your god who is god
who is the god here when i'm kind of
ragged
yeah so many questions people have
second side their head so long
and there are like these spiritual
practices
and the traditions and the disciplines
and
that is uh that is a little maya in
itself
i see people meditating for 20 years
reading their books for 20 years
becoming holy unholy righteous and
righteous
prejudiced a whole lot and at the end
and all the disciplines to burden them
and at the end they
die and then unenlightened and which is
very sad to see
when in reality it's it's just stopping
the thing that's going on here
and yeah and well most of
most of the people who i come across
can't believe i am enlightened or i have
done it
only now they are slowly getting a sense
uh otherwise they just took me for
someone who's living in his whole world
yeah uh yeah
that's how bad it is in india the land
the land of enlightenment that's how bad
it is the people around me have no clue
uh uh also uh they think it's the end
all of life
they'll do it after they cross 60 years
of age
why not get enlightened and live a life
much more beautiful
much more blissful much freer
that is lucid dreaming when a guy gets
aware that he's in a dream and he's able
to take decisions in a dream
with little awareness that dream becomes
much more fruitful
colorful and beautiful and here they are
people
going through life and willing to go
through life
choosing to go through life just a slave
it's just so limited
they spend 60 years of life in that
fooling themselves in that
bit of darkness and they want
enlightenment after 60 years of age
we should be pro pro life pro
enlightened life
we get enlightened cross off the list as
quick as possible
and uh create a beautiful world
oh this is this is india this is india
this is the general notion
we should get awakened only after 60
years of age
separate themselves from each other all
the day long
have so many
well have have so many walls that
separate themselves
have so many resentments and
resistances against the people
between themselves all the while and
then and then after 60 years of age they
get
awakened well i hope they get awakened
after awakening though just to stabilize
myself i
i asked i will i did ask for help and
uh take me to this yoga teacher take me
to that yoga teacher
and the guys are as unaware as they
could be
and they're like i you know i don't i
will
i hit the yogurt i
i see the yoga teacher i the first
question i ask is
are you awake it's like are you awake
bro
and uh they're like i want to be normal
awakening is a very big thing awakening
comes at the end of life and
they just they just block all the good
things from themselves just because
the indian tradition promises awakening
only after 16 years of age
i also i
also like uh meditation need not be the
only way to awakening
closing your eyes and sitting it could
happen when you're walking
uh that's the the well
you know of ruby rumi atlas
you know you heard a groovy atlas
that guy was separated from his teacher
and he couldn't handle the separation no
more
he just flung out his arms started
spinning around for 36 hours
at the end of it awakened a guy spinning
around for 36 hours
got enlightened the same enlightenment
which people
come to after 30 years of meditation
deep meditation dark dark deep deep
meditation
and uh there were there was a dancing
aesthetic
with the three dancing ascetics buddha
walks by
one one of them asks how long will i
take to awaken
so that's a three like thirty three
lifetimes and this guy gets detected
and walks away buddha he asks him the
same question how long till i awaken
he says you'll take 300 lifetimes
this guy gets rejected and walks away
there's a third guy who's full of extra
fee
buddha says you will take as much years
as much lifetimes as there are leaves on
that
banyan tree this guy just starts
laughing and he gets awakened that
instant
uh we don't need to take action towards
enlightenment but
let not uh action become your master be
not a slave to action
and that's of course papa yeah
that's of course papaji a disciple of
ramana maharishi
who gave who am i who popular is foreign
used to
have people sit in front of his
blessings uh ask them two or three
questions
and at the end of it it takes badly five
minutes
the people awaken
uh it's basically inquiry done for you
yes and yeah yeah
well well i'm all for instant
enlightenment
yes light me too
me too and i'm actually really happy
that
you bring that up i feel
a really strong pull towards the
instant enlightenment along with
the
the purifying that comes along with a
process
in a sense of there's going to be
moments
when you understand everything as one
intelligence at play with itself
there's going to be moments where you
end up seeing
that am i coming from the creation
serving itself or am i coming from
me wanting to extract something out of
the creation
and so that that will continue happening
and there'll be a purification process
but
you can jump and pierce the veilless
veil
fast rather than slow and
you brought up a lot of good things in
that
last bit i would say that in essence
what we're talking about like we said
earlier
is stopping these couple patterns of the
mind
and as you quiet the mind you unite
with the diamond that's already around
your neck which is that you're always
already free
and perfect and ineffable emptiness
witnessing infinite creation in that
you bring up this really good point
which is that why are people waiting
in the holy land of india the most
spiritual place in the entire world why
are people waiting until they're 60 why
are they
going to maya for six decades and then
they're like okay
the last 20 years i'll try my best to
read some books it's like nope
actually by the age of 10 we can put you
into
like virtual reality pedagogy and we can
walk you through the basic understanding
of the nature of reality very quickly
and then you can be awake in the dream
you can be awake in the dream and that's
lucid dreaming i i really like that a
lot
and it's a state change which is another
thing that's important to mention
is that it's a simple state change drop
the person and become god
drop the person drop the argument
and become god and serve
god this is all god playing with itself
so serve
that rather than trying to extract for
your person
and destroy the world in the process
uh india is a land where five
five-year-old babies were enlightened
they are missing the whole point here
also uh they think after well they have
stereotyped enlightenment so
much they think only the dimensions
get awakened and all their relevances
are other in incense are useless
uh we have a
yeah show them what's possible when once
you awaken
i'm curious what you
think about the fundamental
questions who am i
what is i what is me self-inquiry
atmo go inside
go within turn in word
when you make the recommendation for
people
how do you make the recommendation with
who
am i
uh the game of maya or materialism is
uh how much ever you play it there's
still more to get
and it it still keeps you in the chase
and it never runs the
deciding process and so so it is with
knowledge
as much knowledge as you gain or as much
question as you
put forth uh does it still
leads you on and there's going to be
more questions
and these questions are about the
objects outside
and well
as as much knowledge you acquire it's
still going to be incomplete
something fundamental is going to be
missing whereas self-inquiry
is the knowledge of the self say you
have knowledge of everything in the
universe
but not of the self it remains
incomplete
so you have knowledge of the self and
you are clueless about the universe
you have something of substance it
doesn't matter you can stay soaked in
the blister of yourself
that's that's that's how over
overpowering
overwhelming overpowering it is uh over
over the tiny objects of maya and on the
moment
on the moment of awakening the things
that appear so solid
appeared so rigid and having such
boundaries such
definite properties consciousness just
overwhelms them
the substance which is intensible or
over
well just over shadows the tangible
substances
and it's like floating in consciousness
all the time
the intensible becomes more tangible
than the tangible
yeah yeah
well these are the right questions you
ask to yourself
if you need to keep your sanity against
the world
well well these are the times where
people are
little with insecurity uh well
the times of corona makes it even more
relevant
and so the only place where you can be
secure the only thing that remains where
everything
including your own sense of self
which gets taken away the sense of self
is a
permutation and combination of different
identities
uh life and dislikes you live with these
and
well the objects that the objects that
make up the content of your
consciousness
say i go to this school and this is a
dot here
say uh i have these parents this is a
dot here
and say i like this board this is a dot
here
these are just dots in your mind you
continuing
to live with it day after day these dots
get connected
and a person begins to form and
the more you the more you stay true to
these thoughts or
let these or sustain these thoughts the
more your personality gets
i wrapped around those thoughts so
that's that's how the person is made and
erase the lines and these dots follow
follow
apart by themselves and what is
behind all these what has been playing
the game all along is seen and
there's awakening awareness of becoming
aware of awareness itself
becoming conscious of consciousness
itself making the seers free himself
that's awakened
should i add yeah yeah and awakening
doesn't mean you
need to cover and transcend and master
every part of your mind the mind is
supposed to have 16 parts according to
yoga which
i haven't even read properly uh take
those five those five parts are
which is intelligence and ahamkara which
is identity
and malice which is the flow of thoughts
and buddhi which is the intellect the
rational part and
one other part which i
the only thing that needs to be
dismantled is
the identity the sense of i
cross over this one eye asking who
who really does it who really does it
who am i and
cross this cross over this one eye and
you're done it the rest of the
the rest of the syllabus may not be
completed just do this one thing get
awakened quick
and the world is house to take
yeah enlightenment is not something so
formidable
uh it at least uh it needs a little
little sense a little will to be
indomitable
a little stubbornness i won't give up
till i break this value but
after that it's a piece of cake it's the
easiest thing easiest
yeah yeah and knowledge
acquiring knowledge thinking your
journey towards enlightenment
is uh you're just brainwashing yourself
uh books are the new cults books are the
new cults
oh damn that's something this
well well action is a little necessary
it gives you a platform
to stand on but after that platform it's
up to you to take the leap
uh don't stay stuck in the platform
that is maya and that is spiritual
knowledge and it's up to you to go
beyond both
now having a higher platform a better
platform go beyond it
don't get stuck into it uh the amount of
books you read
does not equal your your spiritual
progress
uh getting through the barrier and
touching that
spiritual progress india
yeah uh uh truth uh process action
so how much of a action you make
well doubles you put i don't know how it
is with meditation
all the meditation type dudes but
don't get stuck in action it's the
better you do it the more
the more painful the separation is
between you and enlightenment the more
painful it gets to continue
even a day without enlightenment and yes
it bothers you so much who goes to sleep
unawakened
you feel like a failure well and nothing
else matters you feel like
only enlightenment matters when it
becomes like this
uh you're willing to yeah at the cost of
your life you're willing to know the
truth
then settle for less and carry on with
life
that's the moment that's the moment an
enlightenment is around the corner
yeah yeah basically what can ask who am
i
i i don't think of organizing triathlons
in india
and mix in inquiry with it and somehow
turn it spiritual
well that is a purity to physical
practice
spiritual and physical athletic
practices and
mixing inquiry with it goes a long way
maybe 100 people sign up for the race
and 10 people awakened by the end of it
i love the quote like you said floating
in consciousness all the time is a good
one i like how you said maya's carrots
and never end
i like how you said that something
fundamental will be missing even if you
collect all of the knowledge of form
infinity something will be missing aka
your knowledge of the very seer the
observer the witness awareness beingness
itself the i
am will be missing that
the very self distortions
are all of the permutations in the
possibility space of likes
and dislikes and attachment
and seeking validation
and person energy contraction all of
your
childhood conditioning this is the space
of the distortion this is the space of
the argument of god
with god you argue with god and so
yep and then i like how you brought up
amkara which is one of my favorite
words as well because the identity is
key this is a big game of identity it's
all about identity are you the person
are you the awareness are you the very
source
of at all are you the very source of
infinite possibility itself the very
emptiness in which everything arises and
goes right back to
are you that because if you are that you
win
and you serve the creation from there
but if you're
even if you're even if you are awareness
i've seen people sort of get into the
point where
they hold awareness but their personal
awareness
they don't even go impersonal with the
awareness
and they don't make it even eternal and
so this is what's important to also
decipher as well and
i like how you brought up that books are
the new cult
it's important to know yeah
yeah yeah you can't have in the classic
videos there's
you know you have all these interviews
happening and the person that's being
interviewed has this
bookshelf behind them and they have you
know a thousand books on the shelf and
and that's what makes them so
intelligent
but you ask them you know what is i
who am who are you what is you
and at that point you'll tell
that the energy is the contracted person
because you really just need this flip
inward analyze inward
go inward until you get to the very
emptiness to the very black hole itself
that is right there at the center of
your eye the very pupil itself is there
it's we we put all of these codes
into the game and they're
they're s they're right there so simple
in front of our eyes and
we're overlooking them all the time yeah
oh yeah yeah it's
it's so simple uh yeah
uh books yeah yeah yeah
uh and the floating in consciousness
part
there is a saint in india his name is
kabir he was a beaver
which is a kind of economically poor but
he said it is like fish swimming in
water all the time
searching for water yeah uh a human
searching for truth is as
well that's how ridiculous it is it is
like fish floating and what you're
searching for they are floating in
consciousness
all the time and uh yeah when you ask
them
who are you to all these knowledgeable
big big people in the world all the big
wigs
they just all this lag comes out
they put on the cool guy attitude uh i
am me this is who i am
here yeah well i haven't even
uh seen stockman who does non-dual
hip-hop
yeah yeah uh described himself in such
bigger dragon
show and uh what else did you say
hapless i feel like another good topic
for us to talk about
would be what has happened in the last
maybe year how long have you been doing
interviews now
of people that have awakened what three
months ago
cool three months so what has happened
in the last three months so basically
since the beginning of this year
and by the way i want to share with you
that
amanda rizzo you know her song
anata i loop that you posted to your
account
right yeah okay so you posted that to
your account
and then what happened was
that when i um when i was listening to
that
that's when this started coming up
so that's when i started going to the
very
meeting place of self no self
and i was
so grateful because it was
your sharing of her
incredible musical art that
triggered this sort of
more true deep inquiry
into the very simulation the very
intoxicative illusion
of the sense of i itself and
that's when i sort of started popping a
little bit more from
the atman to the anatomy or to the anata
itself
and then sort of really vortexing in the
creation expressing itself
interacting with itself and so i'm
really grateful for you guys
and that
that's the type of stuff that i would
say
is the some of the coolest stuff that
you've been doing
is when you get a good piece of
awakening
you share that and then that i check it
out sockman checks it out etc
and that's sort of how we go
[Laughter]
and so you do a good job of that so what
sort of happened in the last three
months walk us through
interviewing awaken people and what's
been happening yeah oh
i started the page just to rant against
me
being misunderstood they were taking me
to the therapist and the therapist had
no clue
they asked me do you want to be in yogi
i tell them i'm already a yogi they
asked me
do you think you are enlightened i tell
them if i don't think anything i'm
enlightened
um
i love the question did they ask you do
you think you're in line you're like if
i don't think anything
and i'm in line it was
getting ridiculous over there and
there was 10 days of therapy remaining
and they said don't talk about
enlightenment don't understand what
enlightenment is and i quit it
i was like uh well what better
but what what else am i here for if not
for enlightenment
uh we we have the ticket to the great
freedom
so i and people are so ignorant and
people are
in so much suffering i thought i'd work
for it and
i'm just ranting out i'm just venting
through this page uh
whatever occurs to me and there's this
guy called uh brendan wisman
who lives in first nations canada he had
two glimpses of awakening but they
collapsed
two saturdays but they were not
permanent
there's the saint called ramakrishna
paramahamsa in india
he had three awakenings before he fully
awakened
uh i did well well uh
brendan was called bipolder and the
first message i sent him is
you're going beyond uh polarity which
stan which is the polar part and you're
going beyond duality which is the bypass
bipolar you're going beyond polarity and
duality
and i tell them and i just hit them up
with
and they just tell them about the world
i just tell them about the who am i
uh if i suffer who suffers if i'm
confused who's confused
uh uh well coming from a back
coming from the background of fitness he
says i'll superset
my gym sets with inquiry and three days
later he awakened fully
and that's number one uh
it's in my page uh it's called before
christ and
brendan's awakening that's january 24
2021
and i used to post this in stories
and brendon's friend nathan alexander
willis
who lives in tennessee usa he asks me uh
i'm kind of
i'm kind of anxious but how should i get
enlightened
i again hit him up with the who am i he
takes notes
and eight days later he's awakened
that's the greatest thing i've done with
this place
i love feeling your service right now
yeah yeah
uh the rest is this there is just well
there is
just working from just so many uh so
many people are
so many dm's with so many people so many
doubts are being cleared and
i'm just here for them as a presence
just to
address their confusions queries and
concerns uh
just here as well just here
just here for them to look at until they
look at themselves
and just suggest works and
they suggest works in progress just
suggest people uh practicing who am i
yes and uh just like who am i
exclusively
not recommended well
do explore yourself in other spiritual
practices
some might help you center yourself some
might help you calm yourself
but inquiry is some might help you
explore mystical
mystical times but enquiry is very
direct
it's just uh you having an argument with
your mind
uh cornering it not taking no for an
answer
just uh yeah just not putting up with
the tantrums of the mind
not putting up with the mind basing all
the time just penetrating
penetrating uh the penetrating the
thoughts with the hope
and and uh reaching to and reaching to
the core of your concept
that's the very self
oh yeah uh i got two people awakened
that's the only
that's the thing i'm most glad about uh
in these three months
you've been creating way more than
right you feel like it's been getting
to people awaken but you've even been
contributing so much
to me and my process and many others
that
have underwent a process when you
interview people
you make them including me reflect
on their own process which then
further creates more insight
into their process and and then they
share that with their audience and that
kind of a thing so
it's really important how many people
have you interviewed
uh how many people have i interviewed
yeah has it been like a hundred
how many people have you asked those
five
questions to oh yeah well many people in
the written world
how many people in the written form
if if it seems like you've asked so many
more
did you interview did you do eben yet
i've been britain did he respond
oh and then he responded and
uh when i am talking with him
yeah yeah it wasn't an interview with
evan britton
it's uh me
okay and then did you message
sonya
okay i'll i'll connect you with her
she's a
close friend i'll connect you with her i
would love for her to do the
interview and i just i love one of the
things that i love about
what you're doing also is instagram
is like a blockchain
so you have all of the timestamps
of all of these different people's
awakenings and their
answers in your feed and i think that
you'll be looked back at as somebody
that did this process
and i think that that's a really
important role to have in the awakening
and so even these types of things very
similar to what we do on the show
when we ask people about their journeys
and their awakenings
very similar these are like time stamped
videos about people satori and whatnot
right and so i think that that's a cool
role for you potentially to explore
is being more excited about
if it's in your highest excitement to
ask people hey answer these five
questions about your awakening
and if they're high caliber enough then
feature them on the page
yeah yeah yeah uh
i just think my interviews are so
simplistic
i was i loved them how to make it run
another
i love them i think that's so beautiful
there's nobody else doing it there's
nobody else that's doing the very
simplistic like
five of the most like high level
questions about
you know let's check if you're awakened
right what are your answers to these
five questions
i think it's so cool i think it's
so cool it's really resonating with me
and so if it resonates with you
i'll keep making really good intros and
i would love for
that to grow i think it's very powerful
it's powerful uh okay i'll go i'll go
ahead with that format then
well something simple for the
enlightenment world
it's really cool let's see how that
unfolds let's see how it unfolds
cool so
let's see i would like to ask
you about
give us a little bit of context tell me
if i'm right here
the same awareness that is here
the same awareness that is there okay
the same awareness of all the viewers
that is shiva the universal formless
self yes
cool will you share yeah share with us
more about shiva please
yes
uh it's like uh you now
it's like taking a photograph there is
this entire big reality
and a camera becomes a little screen you
look through
uh likewise there is this big cosmos
and the one who will and the seer
himself looking through it
but with this little brain he filters
and
it's a filtered consciousness and this
looks at
the world in his own unique way and this
individual looks at world in his own
unique way
zoom out a little bit and you see
through the eyes of this ear and yeah
yeah
it's like taking a photograph really
a different different set of eyes well
that's the fear
which looks at everything and there's
this guy who looks at a little limited
thing and that is the camera
which looks at something even more
limited
zooming out and becoming the cosmic
consciousness
exactly
yeah i also think
we need to uh
well at least in we need to bring uh
things like silent retreats which are
not more accessible
and more different in india
it's uh it's in very few places right
now and
much more people could benefit uh
have they had an acl access
yeah the fact that there's a vipassana
center
in california in north fork that i've
been to four times
has been life-saving for me from the age
of 23
until now about five or so years because
the
ten the ten day silent sits are
the some of the most profound
disciplined ways to access this
top these are the teachings of the
buddha taught through the theravada
buddhism tradition and
disseminated further by sm gowenka and i
highly highly recommend us to create
more satsang
style community truth community of
mirroring to each other emptiness
and it's actually becoming more and more
in high demand
you'll notice like why is your inbox
getting so many more people
mine sockmans many of our inboxes are
getting
more and more people's interest and it's
because
people want a pure reflection of the
nature of reality
and so
yeah yes exactly
everyone needs mostly agents who are
really free
the world needs more free agents who are
really free uh
this just people who are making it uh
accessible and easier for people
without the scary rules and the
larger the the larger than life
uh
well the larger than life imagery of
enlightenment and the
earlier than the imagery of the
enlightened ones
yeah well
how has it been for you after
enlightenment
you know what's been most interesting is
that
getting this so-called in the interview
i responded
the one that you gave me i said that
in december there was this
sort of macro level
satori into
the very shared impersonal awareness
and when i got that pop i was like this
is it the [ __ ] screen this is the
shared screen and it gets the
modulations infinitely
i see it i get it with infinite creation
i get it and it was interesting because
that first pop it deepened
so much when i understood emptiness
source void avoid
shoot um infinity and
when i grasped so there was another
layer to it
which was the emptiness and the
infinitive
truly at its extent and not
just becoming aware of the impersonal
awareness
so it deepened for me a lot in february
and then even now
in april it's been even more deepened
yep
you're going to become even more
deepened in the awakening and you're
gonna become
even more like a travel agent
helping like a true
bodhisattva that can navigate all of
these different lenses
and help people yeah
yeah yeah
yep
what what's the name again
send it send it to me in the private
chat and then i'll put it in the i'll
put in the search bar
[Music]
that's the guy uh that's the guy the
left most immense avalokite
the earthly manifestation of the
self-born eternal buddha
amit whose figure is represented in his
headdress and he guards the world
in the interval between the departure of
the historical buddha gautama and the
appearance of the future buddha
maitreya oh cool
interesting yeah
i went through a really really dark time
uh when my 11th grade ended and my first
day was
yet to begin and i was sending him
lots of players oh the bodhisattva who
embodies the compassion of all buddhas
oh that's beautiful
wow
this bodhisattva is variably depicted
described portrayed in different
cultures as a male female tibet is known
as
chenrezig
wow the bodhisattva who embodies the
compassion of all
interesting
all this is perfect the cries of
sentient beings who need help
exactly exactly
the key i would say is
that that i've been learning is that you
have
no attachment whatsoever you have
the strong
presence energetically to heal
those with the confused seeking impulses
but you have no attachment whatsoever to
the outcome and you also have no
attachment just like in karma yoga no
attachment to the fruits
at all yeah yeah
a hand and full of indian bread and
searching for dogs
that that was most of my walking uh i
did this for eight months
i and was at the end of my wits and
it was at that night i awakened oh i
asked yeah i asked oh
i asked for my just once
that was my first attempt and i got to
yeah you said that you were feeding you
were taking bread and you were feeding
dogs
right that's what you were doing yeah
and that you
i thought you said that you had asked
yourself multiple times
to who am i no well
it was uh one night and my first attempt
was it uh began and end ended uh with
that one walk
that i i yeah
oh the first attempt at really getting
into
who who is it that has to go to class
yeah oh that's so interesting really
it just can be that
and then the three days of sort of
relax in in the in the
in the floating in consciousness
uh yeah basically
my mind is at its width and it cannot
think of any other thing
any other way out and my heart is
burning
it won't go another day without
enlightenment of course
add it to added to it the impending
add it to it the depth like situation so
oh wow
that's that's how it worked uh just me
i'm going on that lonely walk asking for
my mail uh
five or six times and it got over
yeah oh and
yeah and uh
after uh well after dropping out
and spending one year in this
in the yoga nidra of in the in the yoga
of schizophrenic
dosage i am just getting
back into my new college and tying some
loose ends
things are not trying to get back and
and connect to that identity of the one
well i don't want to be finished
engineering was
so horrible and enlightenment helped me
persevere through it
and uh now being complacent and losing
touch with
enlightenment would it would be a very
weird disconnect
yeah totally so
so this is this would be
some something interesting to
think about too is why don't we also
support you via patreon
you know why don't we create a
vehicle for you when you do get the
also one-on-one inquiries that you can
create a you know 50 bucks an hour or
whatever it is
for you know on video call or whatever
right let's create the monetization
because it's basically an exchange
of time and information and whatnot
right so
um let's explore because let's
let's make this something that you can
actually do full time
we need you to do this full time to
ignite the awakening
you can't go do something else and then
expect to
ignite the planetary awakening
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and uh i know towards the end
yeah do you have a patreon
yeah do you have a patreon account
i i i do i do okay well
let's put the link um you send me the
link to the patreon account we'll join
it
and then we'll also put it in the bottom
of the video and then other people can
also
join it and that can be a good way and
then also
um you know get more you know we can say
this right now like
if you guys want to get a one-on-one
session with shiva
you know we'll also explore you know
maybe you can do a little 15-minute
like consultation right for people and
then if they want to continue for
you know an hour you can you know charge
50 bucks for that or whatnot and you can
put that little link in the bio
but that's that's a good way for you to
also
be able to create financial
success for exchange of time and
information that then enables you to
further enlighten the planet
yes sir
yeah yeah and yeah uh
we need to make it uh relevant for the
people uh
here we are the enlightened beings here
are the guys by the sides we are not
sages on the stages
we are much more accessible now
exactly so cool so we got that we'll
have those links in the bio for everyone
i think that's that's a good that's a
good wrap
shiva this has been a pleasure and honor
yes sir thank you so much for your thank
you so much for
thank you so much for giving me this
platform hey
you're a huge inspiration to me and so
many others and this is very important
for you to know at your young age that
you've been creating massive
pivotal catalytic influences on
those that have been seeking the true
nature and you've been making
very profound awakening shifts for us so
we love you we adore you
thank you and know that
and we want you to keep doing this so do
the interviews we'll get the patreon
link down there we'll
potentially get people lined up to do
some
sessions with you so let's let's get
this financially rolling too
perfect perfect all right
that's all folks thanks for tuning in we
adore you infinitely
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode
let us know what you're thinking like
the video if you brought your value
helps the algorithm subscribe to the
channel if you haven't yet and share the
video with people that you feel like
this would profoundly
affect remember very simple question who
who
who am i all you have to do is break two
to three patterns
in your own mind get enlightened first
become aware in the dream of life this
is
lucid dreaming floating in consciousness
all the time
the seer freeing himself if i don't
think
anything then i'm enlightened
empty space
yeah now this interview ends so should
your lifetimes
are suffering just abide in silence
just abide in silence
using your breath
calmly inhale
calmly exhale
and just become aware that you exist
become aware of your own being become
aware of your own awareness
and become aware that you are the very
source of this reality itself
there is only one intelligence present
and it's all interacting with itself
there is only life
okay